[Music]
are you struggling with slow application
development is it impacting your
company's ability to innovate if so
you're in the right place
welcome my name is mid Nguyen and I'm a
senior product lead for firestore
we have an action-packed agenda today
that will cover how firestore is helping
customers more quickly develop
applications
you'll also hear from vladim sapitsky
Chief technology officer at Forbes
Vadim will show how Forbes is using
firestore in other gcp services in order
to innovate app Forbes
and we'll wrap up today's session with
some very exciting feature announcements
for firestore
let's get started
at the root of slow application
development is complexity
first software companies often have to
hire for multiple disciplines in order
to build each layer of their application
for example you'll often have to hire a
team of tdas a team of back-end
engineers and a team of application
Developers
second
coordinating projects across each of
these teams can be very daunting
and third once you've launched an
application you'll have to think about
the operations and scalability of the
back end services that support it with
serverless Technologies Google cloud is
helping manage the heavy lifting of
back-end operations
that means the scalability availability
and even some aspects of security for
each layer of your software stack
a common serverless stack is composed of
firestore for your database
Google Cloud run or functions for your
microservices
and apogee for your API Gateway
serverless Technologies are great
however they don't address the
architectural or organizational
complexity that you face When developing
an application
so one major investment that we've been
making on firestore is a mode of access
in which we call back-end as a service
this enables customers to focus on
application development and delegate the
rest of their backend to firestore
application developers can simply
install the firestore sdks within their
applications and interact with firestore
in a secure and direct manner
it also means circumventing the need for
things like API gateways load balancers
and micro services
and when you combine back-end as a
service with other Universal application
development Frameworks like flutter or
react you'll be able to maintain a
single code base and deploy across all
major platforms including those on the
mobile
web
and even on desktop
the result is that you can now hire for
a single application development team
and that team has the agency to make
decisions
that type of transformative model of
developing applications is what really
Spurs rapid innovation
so to summarize you can use firestore
both as a serverless document database
and a backend as a service
and to demonstrate that flexibility
firestore offers sdks for the most
popular
languages and platforms
on the administrative site we also offer
Integrations for common tools like
terraform
so let's take a step back for a moment
to examine Google's overall investments
in application development
at Google we're investing in a complete
ecosystem for application development
Firestorm seamlessly integrates with
each of these portfolio and dustness
for example as you can see in the top
right of this diagram fires to store
supports sdks for the most popular
Google operating systems and UI
Frameworks
in the bottom right you can see that
firestore supports Integrations with
Firebase in-app services to manage
aspects like user Authentication
application Health monitoring and even
monetization via ads
and on the left you can see that
firestore is fully integrated with
Google Cloud backend services
for example firestore can stream changes
directly to bigquery
we realize that when building an
application our developers frequently
rely on third-party services as well
and that's why we offer TurnKey
extensions per popular third-party
services
these extensions address common needs
like search Payment Processing
communication and even Ai and ml
they're implemented by seamlessly
syncing data between firestore and these
third-party services
so in summary firestore is focused in
helping you rapidly innovate and realize
time to value for your applications
we've seen incredible momentum in fact
over 4 million firestore databases have
been created to power mobile web and iot
applications
you can also have the confidence that
firestore will scale to your
application's needs
in fact we're proud to share that
firestore now Powers over 1 billion
monthly active end users using Firebase
Alt
okay hopefully I've gotten you really
excited about firestore
I'm now going to hand it over to Vadim
savitsky the chief technology officer
app Forbes
thank you mean it's great to be here
we've been working with gcp now for over
three years and I'm excited to share how
we used firestore and other Google
products to innovate
I'll touch base on our mission what
we've been up to at Forbes and some of
the Innovative platforms that we've
built and how we use firestore to do it
so we're Forbes we are media and
information company we have been around
for over 105 years but our mission
really hasn't changed that much over
those 105 years
the mission is to give people the
knowledge resources inspiration and
connections they need to achieve success
we have large and engaged audience
around the globe about 140 million
people in our full ecosystem we are in
the top 100 domains in the world and
around top 50 in the United States we
have a large and unique Newsroom with
over 200 to two and a half thousand
journalists and contributors we create
thousands of high quality content pieces
every month and we also host a variety
of live hybrid and virtual events
we went through successful digital
transformation and we really couldn't
have done it without putting technology
and data at the center of everything
that we do at Forbes
our business was changing rapidly and we
were scaling very very quickly and we
needed modern best-in-class tech
solutions to support it
we needed something that would be able
to scale to support our growing Creator
base as well as our large audience we
looked at the of the Shelf Solutions but
we quickly realized that we needed to
build them in-house to meet all our user
client and business needs and really to
have an advantage over the competition
part of the transformation for us was
moving to the Google Cloud which we did
pretty quickly in about six months
we fully Embrace Cloud native and
serverless and I use a full Suite of
Google Cloud products from bigquery
cloud functions Pub sub to composer and
firestore
so Wi-Fi store well first of all we love
that it's a managed service we would do
not want to be in the business of
managing databases
it has a flexible document model which
makes it very easy for developers to use
and it integrates really really well
with all the products that gcp has to
offer
and here are some use cases for us one
codename Tamagotchi it's our analytics
and insights platform dirty AI assistant
which is part of our publishing platform
and also we use it for article working
birdie is our data-driven publishing
platform we provide close to real-time
deep insights and analytics for all our
journalists and contributors it allows
them to optimize their content Based on
data as well as to understand how the
content resonates with different
audiences
and not only that we provide that data
to them but we also provide invaluable
feedback and recommendations on how to
optimize the content and we do it by
using something that we call AI
assistant
things like what headline would perform
best what images links what keywords do
well in the SEO
and maybe the most important part is
that the platform itself makes it
extremely easy to create engaging
storytelling in a variety of different
formats virtually really allows us to
support all of our diverse businesses
next uh I'll talk about Tamagotchi our
analytics and insights platform
and this platform is available to all
our journalists and contributors in our
publishing platform party we provide
provide detailed information on how
their content is performant and who
their audiences are what platforms it
performs best on how loyal the users are
how many followers they have or how many
subscribers they they acquired what SEO
keywords perform well and many many
other data points as well
so here is the architecture of the
Tamagotchi our data warehouse has over
400 different data sources with billions
of different data points
here we collect data from Google
analytics from our CMS from our ESP as
well as Google search console
and then we process the data into Data
marks
the data marked with historical data
real-time intraday data as well as
events data Mart and that we do
calculations and push the data into
firestore in the format that can be
easily delivered both to our journalists
in the publishing platform
it's calculated based on time frame for
our journalist authors as well as based
on each article
and we deliver it to our CMS and live to
the website as well
second feature I want to talk about is
bird AI assistant it's an assistant that
really helps our journalists to optimize
the content right when they're creating
the story and it provides the feedback
loop it provides real-time
recommendations things like headline
suggestions image recommendations
keyword linking and generating summaries
and descriptions as well
and here's a quick look at the
architecture this one is using
firestore SDK the previous architecture
showed we actually have an API on top of
Firestorm but here you can see that
feedback loop every time the content
body gets updated we write it to
Firestorm and Cloud function detects the
update in firestorm
and starts to execute each Cloud
function is a separate skill
one would be headline optimization the
other would be image recommendation
skill
it processes the data and writes it back
into Firestone writes back all those
recommendations and our CMS bird detects
the change and seamlessly displays it to
the user
and uh thanks a lot for having me this
is how we use firestore and all the
amazing Google products at Forbes thanks
Vadim it's exciting to see the ways that
Forbes is using firestore to drive in
addition
and in this next section we'll be
covering new feature announcements
frequently application success can lead
to anxiety for example to Europe
back-end Services scale to your growing
user base
today we're excited to announce that
we've made enormous investments in order
to remove all limits on right throughput
and client connections
this should give you the confidence that
firestore will scale to your workloads
needs
and as our database grows we know it's
important for you to be able to remove
outdated documents and to save on
storage costs by doing so
time to live you'll be able to Define an
expiration date for each document and
rely on firestore to clean up expired
documents
and as your company becomes successful
your number of applications and
databases are likely to grow
with tag support you'll be able to group
firestore databases along with other gcp
resources
together to observe both Billy and to
apply policy
the next set of features are really
focused on developer enhancements
a top feature request for firestore has
been an aggregation function
for example in Social applications you
may want to know how firestore is
counting the number of frenzy user has
I'm excited to share that we'll soon be
rolling out a preview version of the
count query function
we understand that performance is also
an important aspect of your application
even when those queries might be running
on the local cache
client-side indexing on device queries
will be able to achieve top performance
okay
sometimes authoring a query can be
pretty challenging
furthermore consuming large sets of
results can also be pretty daunting
to help we've launched a new in-console
query Builder and table View
that helps ensure that everyone can
easily author queries and consume large
results
lastly we are continually investing in
Integrations that help you achieve more
with less
for example customers frequently utilize
cloud storage and firestore together
as a result we're adding support for
cross product security rules which
allows you to determine whether access
should be authorized to a given cloud
storage object based on metadata that
might exist Within firestore
lastly I'm happy to share three new
third-party extensions for firestore
with the Vonage extension you'll be able
to set up video calls and reference them
in the database
this is perfect for use cases like tech
support
with purchasly
you'll be able to set up payment
processing and subscriptions
and those will be reflected in firestore
as well
this is great for cases where you want
to build run or even test paywalls
lastly with melee search you'll be able
to replicate firestore data to the melee
search search engine I hope you are as
excited about this session as I was
but it's coming to an end
we encourage you to get Hands-On with
firestore using our quick start guides
learning series and labs
in most cases you'll be able to get
started and complete your first project
in under an hour
if you have any questions during that
Journey we encourage you to post
questions on stock overflow
my name is min and I hope you enjoyed
today's session bye for now
[Music]